ich habe mein name ist so kommen wir
spielen heute länder die menschen das
ist 2012 raus gekommen und ich spiele
damit das ganze aber nicht allzu
langweilig da ist mir die packung
aufgesprungen ich habe mir
wäscheklammern im supermarkt gekauft und
wenn ich immer irgendwie mich erschreckt
damit hab ich ja was ist denn los mit
diesem fall immer wenn ich den sender
sehe oder eine seite oder so ein moment
um finden kann was muss ich überhaupt
finden ich weiß gar nicht genau
jedenfalls stecke ich mir dann sondern
wäsche kann man irgendwann die frage
warum hat schon gewitters papier hat
sich irgendwie die qualität von dem
spiel runter gekegelt ich habe keine
ahnung warum aber ich hoffe es gefällt
euch trotzdem viel spaß noch wir laufen
einfach mal rum es gibt ein paar mehr
möglichkeiten und alle meinten
unspielbar fullscreen mache ich jetzt
auch mal war und der im regent street
auf was habe ich da gerade hingeworfen
ich hab grad space gedrückt weil ich auf
die schüler zu springen musste aber
wollte aber irgendwie habe ich dann wohl
sondern bloß die grad hingeworfen alles
klar alter die vorgänge sehen nicht
gerade vertrauenserweckend aus ich will
mich weiter von diesem scheiß pc mac
sitzen das ist weil die schleizer sagt
von hier aus dass ich einer bin oder
sonstigen nun schlüssel ich dachte schon
dass er jetzt wieder irgendwas gewesen
gerade ja ich bin einfach etwas horror
spiele angeht
das braucht sie mir nicht sagen das weiß
ich
hallo was das regatta memento also eine
wäscheklammer in die k o gott der das
war vielleicht ein blöder entscheidung
jetzt rede ich das ganze video metern
alles klar freunde
ich hoffe jetzt einfach nur noch die
sahure beutel was fällt dir ok next
level was ich mache ein bisschen anders
war das echt krass die hitze ist ja denn
direkt da also ich habe mich noch nie so
krasse beim leben erschrocken du dich
doch ist das a und o
ich habe wieder so stark fallen lassen
was sogar wieder die zeller gesehen das
heißt die liste geht
okay wir haben die nächste wäscheklammer
start es hätte ich so dass das mega weh
tut oder so ich weiß auch gar nicht ich
fasse euro gestern statt wo das sieht
auf jeden fall sehr vielversprechend aus
hier gerade auch das ist der staat
das tut einfach viel zu gehen
guckt euch mal auge an walter ok steckt
die wäscheklammer einfach hier unten hin
das ist glaube ich nicht ganz um sie ist
runtergefallen alles klar wie andere
wäsche kann einfach hierhin meine fresse
jetzt sah das ist der grund warum ich
mir die einfach scheiß ohren ps ich
machen werde das ist doch das tut
einfach nur weh aber ich kann schneller
laufen fällt mir gerade auf ich kann
schneller laufen das ist als die sache
ist halt ich weiß nicht wie diese wo
rettung aussehen
das ist halt das blöde beiden alten ich
habe dann irgendwas eingesammelt bei dem
länder bei dem ersten video was ich
gemacht habe wo ich dieses zitronensäure
tricks wusste dass verleger ich euch mal
hier
da könnt ihr das anschauen da war es
noch so dass da wenigstens seiten waren
das heißt man hat gesehen okay da wahre
seite die musste ich mehr zu holen
aber hier weiß man weiß ich ja gar nicht
was nicht mehr wollen was okay ich kann
da jetzt durch nicht mit euch gerade den
schlüssel eingesammelt abgesehen davon
dass mir meine beiden ordner meine da
sind wir tot war ja auch diese scheiße
ich hoffe einfach immer aus versehen
diese dicke war ich denke spaces
springen
ich will das nicht mehr
ich will nicht mehr bitte länder kommt
einfach und töte mich wenn es nicht
schon genug wäre da wo holsten oder
toilette gehe ich mal abgesehen davon
dass das alles megabyte gerade kommt mir
auch stopp durch die nase
ich hab schlüssel gefunden alter ich
will nicht mehr
ihr habt keine losberger bestimmt und
länder jetzt kommt auch noch so ein
scheiß blitzen ein rentner allein lass
mir mein geiles bein
denn ich muss weiter stellen muss die
scheiß moment trotzdem alles klar
ich habe
[Musik]
watson spielt dort erich dier gerade
noch zwei mal gesehen hat muss es
eigentlich noch zwei wäscheklammern in
die fresse steckt so ich habe alle welt
an ihrem gesicht wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich höhere
bewertungen freuen wenn ihr wieder
challenges wollte anstatt gestalteten
spieler die kommentare
es tut viel zu sehr weh bitte lass ich
das